so is everybody heard of CRISPR I would
be shocked if you hadn't this is a
technology it's it's for genome editing
and it's so versatile and so
controversial that it's sparking all
sorts of really interesting
conversations should we bring back the
woolly mammoth should we edit a human
embryo and my personal favorite how can
we justify wiping out an entire species
that we consider harmful to humans off
the face of the earth using this
technology this type of science is
moving much faster than the regulatory
mechanisms that govern it and so for the
past six years I've made it my personal
mission to make sure that as many people
as possible understand these types of
technologies and their implications now
CRISPR has been the subject of a just a
huge media hype and the words that are
used most often are easy and cheap so
what I want to do is drill down a little
bit deeper and look into some of the
myths and the realities around CRISPR if
you try to Chris for a genome the first
thing that you have to do is damage the
DNA the damage comes in the form of a
double strand break through the double
helix and then the cellular repair
processes kick in and then we convince
those repair processes to make the edit
that we want and not a natural edit
that's how it works
it's a two-part system you've got a cast
nine protein and something called a
guide RNA I like to think of it as a
guided missile so the cast nine I love
to anthropomorphize so the cast nine is
kind of this pac-man thing that wants to
chew DNA and the guide RNA is the leash
that's keeping it out of the genome
until it finds the exact spot where it
mashes and the combination of those two
is called CRISPR it's it's a system that
we stole
from an ancient ancient bacterial immune
system the part that's amazing about it
is that the guide RNA only 20 letters of
it are what target this system this is
really easy to design and it's really
cheap to buy so that's the part that is
modular in the system everything else
stays the same this makes it a
remarkably easy and powerful system to
use so the guide RNA and the Cassadine
protein complex together go bouncing
along the genome and when they find a
spot where the guide RNA matches then it
inserts between the two strands of the
double helix it rips them apart that
triggers the Cassadine protein to cut
and all of a sudden you've got a cell
that's in total panic because now it's
got a piece of DNA that's broken what
does it do
it calls its first responders there are
two major repair pathways the first just
takes the DNA and shows the two pieces
back together this isn't a very
efficient system because what happens is
sometimes the base drops out or a base
is added it's an OK way to maybe like
knock out a gene but it's not the way
that we really want to do genome editing
the second repair pathway is a lot more
interesting in this repair pathway it
takes a homologous piece of DNA and now
mind you in a diploid organism like
people we've got one copy of our genome
from our mom and one from our dad so if
one gets damaged it can use the other
chromosome to repair it so that's where
this comes from the repair is made and
now the genome is safe again the way
that we can hijack this is we can feed
it a false piece of DNA a piece that has
homology on both ends but it's different
in the middle so now you can put
whatever you want in the center and the
cell gets fooled so you can change a
letter you can take letters out but most
importantly you can stuff new DNA in
kind of like a Trojan horse CRISPR is
going to be amazing in terms of the the
number of different scientific advances
that it's going to catalyze the thing
that's special
about it is this modular targeting
system I mean we've been shoving DNA
into organisms for years right but
because of the modular targeting system
we can actually put it exactly where we
wanna the thing is that there's a lot of
talk about it being cheap and it being
easy and I run a community lab I'm
starting to get emails from people that
say stuff like hey can I come to your
open night and like maybe use CRISPR or
an engineer my genome like seriously I'm
no you can't but I've heard it's cheap
I've heard it easy so we're going to
explore that a little bit so how cheap
isn't yeah it is cheap in comparison
it's going to take the cost of the
average materials for an experiment from
thousands of dollars to hundreds of
dollars and it cuts the time a lot to it
can cut it from weeks to days that's
that's great
you still need a professional lab to do
the work and you're not going to do
anything meaningful outside of a
professional lab I mean don't listen to
anyone who says you can do this sort of
stuff on your kitchen table um it's it's
really it's really not easy to do this
kind of work not to mention there's a
patent battle going on so even if you do
invent something the Broad Institute and
the UC Berkeley are in this incredible
patent battle it's really fascinating to
watch it happen because they're accusing
each other of fraudulent claims and then
they've got people saying oh I signed my
notebook here or there this isn't going
to be settled for years and when it does
you can bet you're going to pay someone
a really hefty licensing fee in order to
use this stuff so is it really cheap
well it's cheap if you're doing basic
research and you've got a lab so how
about easy let's look at that claim the
devil is always in the details we don't
really know that much about cells
there's still kind of black boxes so for
example we don't know why some guide
RNAs work really well and some guide
RNAs don't we don't know why some
want to do one repair pathway and some
cells would rather do the other and
besides that there's the whole problem
of getting the system into the cell in
the first place in a petri dish that's
not that hard but if you're trying to do
it on a whole organism it gets really
tricky it's okay if you use something
like blood or bone marrow those are the
targets of a lot of research now there
was a great story of some little girl
who they saved from leukemia by taking
the blood out editing and putting it
back with a precursor of CRISPR and this
is a line of research that people are
going to do but right now if you want to
get into the whole body you're probably
going to have to use a virus so you take
the virus you put the CRISPR into it you
let the virus infect the cell but now
you've got this virus in there and we
don't know what the long-term effects of
that are plus CRISPR has some off-target
effects very small percentage but
they're still there so what's going to
happen over time with that these are not
trivial questions and there are
scientists that are trying to solve them
and they will eventually hopefully be
solved but it ain't plug-and-play not by
a long shot so is it really easy well if
you spend a few years working it out in
your particular system yes it is
now the other thing is we don't really
know that much about how to make a
particular thing happen by changing
particular spots in the genome we're a
long way away from figuring out how to
give a pig wings for example or even an
extra leg I'd settle for an extra leg
that would be kind of cool right but
what is happening is that CRISPR is
being used by thousands and thousands of
scientists to do really really important
work like making better models of
diseases in animals for example or for
taking pathways that produce valuable
chemicals and getting them into
industrial production and fermentation
vats or even doing really basic research
on what genes do this is the story of
CRISPR we should be telling and I don't
like it that the flashy er aspects of it
are drowning all of the salad
lots of scientists did a lot of work to
make CRISPR happen and what's
interesting to me is that these
scientists are being supported by our
society think about it we've got an
infrastructure that allows a certain
percentage of people to spend all their
time doing research that makes us all
the inventors of CRISPR and I would say
that makes us all the Shepherd's of
CRISPR we all have a responsibility so I
would urge you to really learn about
these types of technologies because
really only in that way are we going to
be able to guide the development of
these technologies the use of these
technologies and make sure that in the
end it's a positive outcome for both the
planet and for us Thanks
you